hello my name is - Alison I organised
the Stanford II colloquium on computer
systems this is a part of the series of
programs that we put together for the
spring quarter of 2020 it's a little
different for us now since we're
sourcing the programs remotely and they
are all going to be distributed via
YouTube in any case our speaker today is
monica lamb she is a faculty director of
the oval open virtual assistant lab and
as four years taught computer science in
at Stanford University she's been doing
some very interesting work here and
perhaps Alexian Siri will have something
to say about it later Monica
go ahead Thanks thank you for inviting
me to speak to this ad and it's a little
bit strange that this is remote and I've
been going to have been attending so
many 8380 talks in the past in person
but this is what we have today and well
I'm very happy to have this opportunity
so I'm not talking about this project we
started about five years ago our
original motivation is really protecting
privacy and as we look ahead we felt
like the virtual what we feel we kind of
observed that the virtual assistant is
going to be the the interface that we'll
be using you know for consumers to reach
the digital world and to protect privacy
we have to have an open virtual
assistant and for for open virtual
assistants to be actually used in
practice it also has to be the smartest
and as a result that we have this long
title building the smartest and open
virtual assistant to protect privacy
we started this lab called the open
virtual assistant lab about a few months
ago actually and we're very excited that
we have a good number of very good
colleagues joining this effort in AI
machine learning natural language
processing systems as well as HCI
because this is truly a
multidisciplinary project and we're very
lucky that New York Times rolled up and
wrote up an article about us about how
we aimed at alexey alexa and Siri with a
privacy minded alternative right so
let's get started let's start with
privacy that's we all know by now with
the Cambridge in the lilica incident
that it is kind of dangerous to have a
single company to all and monetize
billions of people's work billions
people's worth of private data and with
all this information Facebook is an
incredible incredibly powerful
advertising machine they can advertise
products but they can also advertise the
news that they want us to see their
thoughts political opinions and so forth
and they have a lot of influence in
including the influence even on our
election and if you think about this
problem here the the best phrase that I
have heard to summarize the situation we
are in is probably the one coined by
Professor Tim Wu who is a law professor
at Columbia and he he calls this the
tyranny of convenience the ultimate
issue here is that consumers need
convenience if you want to protect their
privacy you have to give them something
that is convenient and the biggest
problem we have today is that there is
just no meaningful choice it's not like
they can say oh I don't want a company
that owns my data but there is really no
easy way for them to share this
information
to share their personal information and
this is something that the technologists
have to have to understand and have to
say if you want privacy you have to
address this tyranny of convenience so
that's what happened
and with the kind of a monopoly that we
see here it's really too late to try to
create an alternative to Facebook what
we need to do is to look forward to the
next big thing we all know that you know
the computer science always evolves and
there will be the next interface and
what we need to do is to protect the
next one and the next one is going to be
the Virtual Assistants for sure voice is
not is the new interface okay this is a
huge paradigm shift you know when we
first have the pcs we have to invent the
mouse we have to invent the display but
now we have these little mobile devices
and we have ubiquitous we have smart
speakers you can just interface with the
computer using the using language the
language is how we talk to each other
and this is machine learning we can now
use language to talk to computers so
voice is obviously huge and in Virtual
Assistants have an incredibly compelling
value proposition you know today we sign
up to this website after you know that
website and we have all these different
accounts all our data I siloed in many
different web services we have to log
into each one of them and do whatever we
need to do so what the virtual
assistants offer here is like just give
me all the passwords I can get access to
all the web sites and I give you a
personalized interface to all these
different web sites you don't have to
worry about looking up you know going
through all the menus and doing XYZ
clicking here clicking there or in the
same way if you look at the mobile apps
look at the IOT devices that you install
around the house and you want to be able
to just talk about them
uniformly so with all this information
they will they will totally
revolutionize how we do everything from
searching to buying anything's like you
don't have to see what you want to buy
because they can read your email and
they know all your planning say a trip
in 2021 okay and it will actually go and
help you find the tickets and so forth
because they know your habits right in
other words the virtual assistant is
going to be the new interface to how we
interact with the digital world and as a
result of that they have a lot of power
on on what services will be using and
they can market a lot of information but
on top of products news political
engineers whatever we have been seeing
in facebook for example it's going to be
even more effective when we get into
this virtual system that sees all of our
personal data so what we can expect here
is that whenever we know of Google
Amazon Facebook imagining all of that
combining to be owned by the virtual
assistant and what is also worrisome
here is that there is a duopoly already
emerging Alexa has 70 percent of the 76
million inputs top base of owners in the
US all right and I think Google is like
25% and the other thing here is that
they are not just a way for you to talk
to you Amazon services they actually
have a pretty incredible third-party
platform right now there are over a
hundred thousand different skills on
this platform so through Alexa you can
talk to many different services so in a
sense you can think of Alexa is like the
new browser using the browser you can
visit all the different pages except the
difference here is that they all those
skills it's open to people to put you
know you can put your skills in but
does a proprietary platform we can
choose to close it we can choose to
ignore a fee you want to be connected
through them if you want to say you want
to sell through us we I mean since this
is my platform I can put on the feet
just not that different from how app
stores today takes a cut on a I think
that's a 30% cut on the revenues that
mobile device mobile apps make okay so
they have a lot of control
besides the skills they also have 60,000
compatible IOT devices those are the
last numbers where you looked up and
maybe there are even more at this point
and in order to make all this happen
they also they have employed over 10,000
people working on Alexa that is a lot of
this is a huge platform and what we are
witnessing in a sense is a proprietary
linguistic web in the making so this can
this is very worrisome there are three
major different threats that are
important here the first one is privacy
will there be one or two virtual
assistants that see billions of people's
private data so that's one the second
one is that it is a platform for that
through which you get to learn about
products you buy products and so forth
so will they become a platform that
controls what are the services that are
being that that we can get access to you
so this potentially can close the market
and without having an open market it
also threatens innovations and the third
problem here is like if the older
technology or virtual assistants were
owned by just this couple of companies
then it doesn't mean that they are the
ones are going to put up all the
services I mean they're going to serve
the kind of you know
to to use they get to pick what they
what they're doing which is very
different from the web anybody can put
up on a website in the language they
choose to so the question is would it be
the problem
would it be the case that the the social
good projects or underserved classes may
not have a chance to take advantage of
the verse appear to assistant technology
what about the rare languages would they
be covering all the languages even
though they may not be the most
profitable languages to worry about okay
so these are three major issues that are
at hand here if we do see a monopoly or
duopoly the tricky part here is that
virtual assistant technology is really
hard there is a huge technical barrier
to entry all right the fundamental issue
here we are dealing with natural
language processing and we know at this
point our best tool is neural networks
and neural networks needs training data
needs annotated training data and if you
want training data then you really need
to have users so almost what is expected
in terms of a prerequisite is you have
to have millions of real users and there
are very few companies that have access
to all this real data all right so this
makes it very hard but some but we also
have to realize that with this approach
there are a lot of deficiencies if you
are annotating real data data is data
from users there is a privacy issue but
if you look at the performance side of
things there's a whole long list of
issues that is worrisome the first is
the cost we already know that they alexa
has like over 10,000 employees right and
we know this you know there are not too
many companies that can afford that
second question is coverage there are
just lots of many possible utterances
can we really annotate all of the data
that we are the conversations that we
need
third is robustness a lot of dialog
student you know dialog today you are
mainly designed or or crafted these
conversational agents are crafted using
dialogue trees where you lay out the
possible questions and and the kinds of
answers that you're expecting and it is
very constrained but in practice we talk
about many things we change topics and
so forth so how do we make it make the
system more robust there is an issue
also of accuracy there is the if you
know of course we worry about the
accuracy of training and the meantime we
discovered that as we try to annotate
data it is also very easy to make
mistakes in the annotations and we will
talk about an example with the mountain
what was that we saw in the multi was
that benchmark then there is a question
of bootstrapping or you don't have the
users or you have a new feature on new
new service that you roll out how do you
get training data how do you even start
then there is the issue of scalability
we talk about how the assistant allows
you to reach like the web linguistically
of my voice there 1.8 billion websites
up there there you know we there are
lots of possible dialogues it can be
made out of those websites and there are
thousands of natural languages being
used so how are we going to scale with
this approach so the summarize here is
that there are many standard performance
meant for performance metrics that are
not done well with this approach and I'm
so if I look at all the lists here I'm
going to clean this term CCR abs to
represent all the six as six the
friends metrics and we're just gonna
pronounce this as craps these are issues
that we have to address if we really
want to see the full potential of the
Virtual Assistants let's take a look at
what we think will happen if we develop
this technology well hopefully with the
help of a lot of people because there's
the the scope of the virtual assistant
is really large the first thing we are
saying here is that we're gonna expect
the whole web to go voice accessible
right it's gonna change how we do some
standard search process you're going to
be able to use your history emails
calendar you can even talk about what
you really care to look for and so forth
so it changes search with voice we can
automate what we want to do without
having or asking some developer to write
up the code there are personal tasks
like ordering groceries food these days
paying bills it would be nice to be able
to automate what you want to do and what
you normally do on the website but more
importantly when you think about jobs
that people do the doctors the sellers
the stock brokers loan officers and so
forth or our teachers they can also
automate their processes the concept
here is that if I can use voice I can
automate this process of what we're
seeing here is this concept of natural
language programming we've been working
on making programming easier and easier
but imagine we can now just look at that
just have consumers use natural language
and they can automate their own tasks
it's a huge concept so when we think
about automation is what we do what we
ask the computer to do then the next
step is that the computer can help us
can advise us what to do again examples
are like fitness bodybuilding and you
know you get to finances education
careers and so forth
as an advisor they can really influence
our behavior for good or for bad there's
a lot of you can manipulate our behavior
and so forth so there is a lot of power
that these virtual assistants can have
on the individuals as you can see here
you know there is a long list of things
that will happen with the development of
virtual assistants and today there are
like 23 million web interface web
developers writing HTML codes and so
forth
I believe that in the future we're
talking about 23 million voice interface
developers because everything needs to
have a voice interface
so given this vision here we really can
we really need to improve the
methodology for creating virtual
assistants to address all the standard
metrics that's that we care about in
computer science this with this
methodology what we would really like to
have is a tool set that enables the 23
million developers to easily create
their interfaces and instead of just
relying on annotating real life
sentences so what we are trying what we
need to do is to create these tools that
we have created a a prototype system a
it's a working system but it still got a
lot of room for improvement for sure the
system is called Jeannie and in empowers
developers to build skills and also
consumers can start using this to
automate some of their tasks and I can
get into details next so the method new
methodology new toolset and on top of
that we have created two platforms the
first one is called thing pedia it's a
little bit like Wikipedia right it is a
crowdsource repository you can put the
skills in here it is open and it is non
proprietary that means that any skills
that you put into this thing pedia is
open to everybody to open to all virtual
assistants this is kind of like the open
internet right anybody can put up a HTML
page and you can't you know you you know
you can create a new browser and visit
all the existing pages you don't have to
have to create the skills for your own
browser so this is the first this is
this is one of the important platforms
and that's the pedia the second is that
we have also built any a Perl type
virtual assistant it's called almond
that uses thing pedia skills and almond
is different from all the other
commercial assistants in the primary way
of how it protects privacy it has a
federated architecture and it supports
interoperability and and thereby it also
protects privacy and I will describe
that at towards the that's a third topic
in the next talk and the next part of
the talk and what I want to focus on now
is to go back to you talk about the new
methodology for building virtual
assistants and the tool sets that we
have created all right
just as we get into the technical side
of things the methodology let's start
with how do you how do you work your
assistance today build there you know
how the virtual assistants are built
today ok so let's start with Alexa and
Alexa has a representation they call a
mrl the Amazon meaning representation
language and this language is syntax
dependent so for example if I pick a
sentence like search for an upscale
restaurant and then make a reservation
for it it maps into some logical form
and I want to get into the details so
I'm just going to give you this
high-level picture imagine the left side
says upscale restaurant the right side
says make a reservation ok but if you
take this example of a sentence I can
see it in any different ways if I say
reserved a high-end restaurant for me
that sentence means exactly the same
thing but it actually will be annotated
differently because
of the of the because of the syntax of
this sentence and what it means is now
is that the same meaning can be
represented in different ways right and
this is syntax dependent so it also
means that if I give you a different
language great such as Chinese here I
mean the representation may be different
and and and so forth so it just means
that this animal tation task is very
complex is difficult and it is not the
same as asking a crowdsource worker if
you look at a picture whether it's a cat
or a dog okay you really need to get
trained in order to do a good job in
creating the logical representation of
those sentences okay so that's how they
represent this information so the Alexa
first you have to annotate and then you
take all this information and then you
train the neural network to generate the
information in their representation then
there is the second step the second step
is that given the a mrl then you have to
interpret it and then you decide what
they're just asking for what it is
asking you to do and then you have to
execute it so they just done in two
steps so we have we cannot afford this
okay
they have 10,000 employees we started
with one PhD two PhD now we have about
four PhD students working on the AI side
of things I cannot afford this approach
and and neither can most companies so we
have to come up with new methodology as
we discussed and a new approach to this
problem so the first idea is that we
have an end-to-end translation technique
the first most important observation we
make made is it I am really not trying
to understand full-blown natural
language alright what we are trying to
do is human-computer interaction and
what that
what what's the users have the humans
have to say to the computers it's just
what we want the computers to do for us
all right so it's like us with a dog and
we just want the doctor understand shake
hands or lie down right we're not going
to start talking about fantasy
philosophies poke trees and so forth
okay so it is much more limited than
human conversations and then the second
part is that it is a computer what can
it do we know we know I mean that the
best is this Turing complete so whatever
the computer the computer can do we can
describe its capability in a programming
language okay it we know eventually it
tries to execute something that was a
second step in the virtual system we
know that if that is the case we can
just summarize what exactly the computer
can do with a language this language its
we because it is something that the
virtual assistant needs to do it is not
a language that we are really have in
the past so we actually came up with
this language we call this thing talk
it's the way things talk to us alright
so so this is a brand-new language that
is intended for this purpose it can
capture the capability of the computer
and it's a language that is extensible
we expect more and more as we improve or
increase the capability of the virtual
assistants we will increase the power of
thing talk and it is absolutely
independent of the source language the
natural language and that is very very
important okay
and given that then now we can so the
task here is that we can take what we
want to do is to take text and then
translate it into the meaning which is
captured by an executable representation
okay it's as formal and it is executable
whatever you want the computer to so you
do
you can capture it using this language
so you can see a little bit like here
search for an upscale restaurant make a
reservation it boils down to calling in
this case say a Yelp API get a get the
result pick something that is expensive
and then we reserve the restaurant okay
so as you see here the query language in
the natural language have there are very
close in the level of obstruction and
this is the reason why the natural
language translation has a chance okay
so this language is really designed to
be generated from natural language so
now what we are talking about is an end
to end translation so you have a neural
network that takes the English sentences
and generate code and what we have
skipped is the intermediate level of
representation all right we what we are
saying here is I just give you the
training and to end and let the neural
network come up with the intermediate
representation it's that's what it is
good for okay so so that's idea number
one so with this representation you've
got any unique semantics we made the
language canonical it means that there
is always one for whatever you want to
say there is one ident one unique
representation for that semantics and
this is very important to be able to
train the neural networks well okay you
whatever way different ways you are
saying it it boils down to the same
exact program okay so here are just all
the different sentences that can that
will translate into that sentence into
that code another thing we can do if you
look at it from this way is that if I
look at that code I can paraphrase it I
can say this this code in many many
different languages with this you can
even use machine translation to help you
generate data if you have a corpus of
English that is English and code and if
they have a perfect machine translator
that translates English into Chinese
then I automatically will have a will be
able to handle the this translation from
natural from Chinese to code okay so
that's the first idea the second idea
here is that we really need to apply the
CS a computer science software
engineering approach to get the training
data we really don't want to just say
just go with the current methodology
which is that you have to have a lot of
data
the big thing up and then we have
annotators we heard that there are
countries that have data factories okay
that annotate data and a lot of people
are notating and then you generate the
training data and then you use it to
train the neural network and if the
result is not good then you have to go
find more real data and do more
annotations and hopefully that will give
you the accuracy that you need all right
so that is a pretty we discuss how it
doesn't have the craps properties so
instead what we are saying here is that
we need natural language data but we
want small amount of it we can only
afford that and we take the small amount
of data and the engineers are going to
amplify it okay you look at the small
data and using the tools that we have we
can generate a lot of training data and
then you use this to get to train the
neural network and the second part that
is most important here is that when the
neural network doesn't behave we can now
look at it and have the engineers or
have the tools automatically tune the
system by generating more training data
in order to improve the neural net the
ability to refine the process is
absolute key okay
so what I want to do in this talk is to
give you a high-level overview of three
results that we have gotten using this
methodology we start with Q&A dialogues
and then we talk about how we handle io
T's and privacy so Q&A so today if you
look at Alexa the if you want it to
answer questions you have to hand code
roughly the training data one by one the
training data corresponds to question
and code if you give me this question
this is the code that will get you the
answer okay and one by one that's a lot
of work right what we are doing however
is that we are going to rely on
synthesis in order to get a lot of the
training data remember we we generate a
lot of data from a small amount of
natural data natural language sentences
and or if you want to create an agent
all you have to do in this bit using
this tool chain is to supply the schema
all right of the information that you
want to create a cue 8 agent or suppose
I'm doing restaurants the schema would
have the name the price you seen and so
forth okay and then you do a little bit
of fuel annotations to talk about how
you use natural language to describe
some of these fields and that's all you
that's all the restaurants come
restaurants have to do ok and what we
provide is a whole bunch of the Romanian
dependent templates there are about 500
of them ok but the best part of this is
that it is still mainly pendent whether
you're talking about hotels there's more
restaurant restaurants taxis drive-in
whatever it doesn't matter it is the
same set of templates we do it once once
and for all for a natural language ok
so if you take that then we have a tool
and it automatically generates a whole
bunch of sentences that can be derived
or that can be answered using the
schemas and we put in joins you know we
you can do projections you can you can
do comparison and so forth and all these
sentences are just trying to diet lis
generator you don't have to coat them up
one at a time so that's a high level
picture let's go down one level so we
said that the user has to provide the
schema the few annotations all this
information goes into thing PDF which is
the platform of all of you know how how
things work okay how we could use voice
to interact with these things so that is
the what the user supply and then the
rest of it is for the tool tools supply
alright so we have a tool it takes thing
talk grammar I mean that part is also
parameterised but of course we have
already got the grammar for Q&A and on
top of that the templates that we talked
about you know what so for example
generically we say what is the field of
table or what is the tables feel like
what is the cuisine of the restaurant
and what is the restaurant scusi alright
so you substitute with different domains
you get different to it Q&A agents so
you take that you synthesize of
sentences in the code if you take a
small percentage of that and you ask me
you ask crowdsource workers to do a
little bit of paraphrasing so we
typically I would say take less than 1%
of the data and ask for the paraphrasing
getting some amount of natural language
sentences is really important to you
compliment the millions of sentences
that we synthesized now you take all
that and we add we take the sentences
and we augmented with parameters and
data and we generate millions and
millions of sentences and we send it
through the for Senate through a neural
network to
the most important thing that we do that
we learn in this process is that while
we are training with this paraphrases of
the synthetic sentences you cannot
evaluate with that you absolutely have
to validate and test it with real user
input and use that to to to tune the
neural network if you just stick with
the paraphrase and since the Sai
sentences you can get a model that works
very well okay but fails in real life so
the key here is that we have to get a
small amount of information but it does
a tiny fraction of what you need for
training and you use that to do the
evaluation what happened if it what
happens is that the first round when you
do that you will find that the neural
network we call it lui net by the way it
says for the linguistic user interface
Network the first round it doesn't do
that well but then you can now look at
the errors and you figure out what is is
that your synthetic sentences miss you
put in those components into the system
and you add in a few more templates in
order to cover the ideas that are
missing the key here is that you are
just throwing in some of the missing
components and the synthesizer will
automatically take the component and
combine it with all the different
components to generate sentences that
you have not seen in practice and this
is very important because if you just
see one particular combination the
neural network can very easily over you
know over learn and just didn't realize
that these are concepts that can be
combined with other things so the key
here is that this approach is how we
teach the neural network
compositionality okay so that's the
validation all right so what can we do
here are some examples of sentences that
we tried and we tested it on alexa
google syria and us
and as you can see here that we can
answer all of these kinds of questions
but the commercial assistants don't do
that well on them so for example if I
say show me restaurants rated at least
four stars with at least 100 reviews we
all know that if there are only a couple
of reviews we should really discard the
rating and so it does a very natural
sentence but that is the kind of
sentences that we can do but we didn't
see any other system doomed because
what's going on here is that these kinds
of sentences require us to do joins of
information in in the in the schema in
the databases and because we are kind of
generating the program directly from the
sentences but using a neuron that
network that was taught compositionality
we were able to answer this kinds of
questions
so these are just a sample we also ran
an experiment where we crowdsource
for about 400 restaurant queries what we
did is that we asked the crowdsource
workers it's like given this kind of
properties about restaurants can you
come up with sentences that use two of
these properties okay so this is not
your regular questions which is what is
the top restaurant in Palo Alto ok a lot
of people you know everybody can answer
that but the kind that I was just
showing you what is a trying you know
Chinese restaurant in Hawaii that has
rating above for that kind of think that
would really that will stump some of
these assistants and what we see here is
that we are reaching close to 75 percent
whereas Alexa and Siri ranges from
30-some to like 50 ish results so we're
pretty excited we this you know we have
a small team and what we are focusing on
is really teaching questions that can be
from a database we kind of go backwards
and as a result we get better coverage
we get better accuracy and those are the
ways we address the craps metrics that I
mentioned earlier okay so so that's the
first result we see is that we can
answer complex queries more accurately
now let's talk about dialogues okay that
is what people really want I mean I
don't want to just give you commands and
get what answer Monty
turns and described discussed this so to
start let me show you how we build
dialogues today it's just typical that
we use the dialogue trees but it is very
laborious and extremely brittle so here
is an example going back to the
restaurants it starts by the agent
saying hello how can I help you and at
that point the agent is there looking
for the high-level intent such as I'm
looking to book a restaurant for
Valentine's Day
so this matches to this reserved action
alright this is in natural language
understanding there's an intent in a
slot that's like okay restaurant then it
has a model given this restaurant I say
I can't given this reserve I know that
you're trying to reserve something I can
ask you for more information
illicit slot or I could show you some
results or I can show you some
recommendations but say in this case it
goes it the system chooses to you ask
for clarification elicits so the slot
and there is a hard coded roughly hot
coded sentence saying something like
what kind of restaurants are you
interested in and at this point the the
system has a set of following up intense
okay there are certain things I expect
you to be saying so for example Tyrone
on California Avenue well that is
exactly one of those things that we
expected is like okay you gave me the
name I'm ready to go okay but if you if
you say something like something that
has pizza okay that I can understand
because I'm expecting food equals to
pizza but if you are not seeing anything
that it is expecting then whoa it cannot
deal it cannot handle it so suppose you
did not expect the user to say I don't
know what do you recommend
all right surely I have you know as you
can see in this diagram here I know how
to recommend things but at under the
illicit slot case I didn't expect you to
be saying it and I just don't know and
at that point I kind of fail
of this tree and this is the reason why
it is very brittle so what I show you
here is an example of a conversation
that's a like a restaurant interface
developer may may layout but in reality
this conversation state is much more
complicated so so so that's one issue
the second issue is that if I now have
to train some system at the level of
dialogues okay as opposed to just
looking at classification of intents
which is also work that is being done
here is to say if you want to understand
the full dialog you have to annotate
these dialogues one at a time
there are lots and lots of possible
dialogues out there and even if I paid
for a lot of annotations it doesn't
necessarily mean they even give me a new
dialogue I'll be able to handle that
really well and on top of that we
discovered that it was actually very
hard to do a good job there is a
dialogue data set called multi wasps it
is actually multi domain dialogues and
what we discovered I mean the the
research community has discovered there
is roughly about thirty percent error in
the annotations themselves and if you
train with this data set that has 30
percent error you know you're not
getting 70 percent accuracy even all
right so so there is this other issue
here is the annotating dialogues and
relying on a dialogues annotated
dialogues to get you the training data
you need is problematic okay so let's go
back to the first question which is the
state size so what we did is that we
looked at some of the the dialogue data
that that's our small data and SS we
look at a sample of that and we realize
that the state's a lot more complicated
so we extracted any
dialogue state machine for transactions
so here is a representation of that and
so for example I can start I can greet
the yellow the orcs are it the orange
note here represent what the let me see
so the orange is what the agent is
saying okay and that I'm sorry the
orange is what the user says and then
the green is what the agent says okay
and as you can see here there is a quite
a bit of complicated flow but the good
news here is is this check this this
model this dialogue state for
transactions is kind of independent of
what domain it is so it is possible for
you to kind of put this domain this
dialogue state together and you know
whatever work you are doing here can be
reused across all the different domains
so using this we are able to create a
technical stack that is very modular
very reusable and so if it is a domain
that we have already done work on so for
example restaurants then a single
summing restaurant can come along and
use this tool by simply supplying
knowledge about it but it's particular
about that particular restaurant like
what concedes they serve and what's the
price range what kind of ratings they
get they supply this and you're able to
generate for for the business a
reservation agent okay so they don't
know what need to know anything about AI
nothing about training and they get an
agent okay but if you look underneath
the hood it is a whole stack of
different tools and I've already given
you all the major ingredients on
components first it is about this
domains in other words so here's an
example
restaurants means I'm gonna use the
restaurant schema restaurant reservation
API and some annotated small data so if
you want to do something that is not in
that domain then you will have to supply
that level of information underneath
that the next level and the stack is
these domain independence sentence
templates okay and and this is language
specific we
a whole there are about 500 of them
right now and it's is useful for all the
different domains for transactions we
have a transaction dialogue state model
but in the future we expect to see more
states models if given this information
we can automatically synthesize new
dialogues after dialogues okay so the
data says I may be the state and under
the state I look up the table and I
supply the content about that particular
domain of the filler restaurant and I
can start spewing out millions of
millions and of dialogues which can then
be used to do can be used for training
and at the end of that you get a
restaurant reservation agent okay so one
interesting project we are doing here
we've got a draft of a submission of a
paper that use the schema.org data
schema.org is the schema that is used by
a lot of webpages so if we're able to
take by working on schema.org we can
potentially take millions of web pages
in the on the internet and make it voice
accessible okay so we talked about a
neural network this neural network is
different is this kind of unique it's
one of a kind it's for dialogues and
what is new about it is that instead of
just just seeing all the sentences for
each turn we use any context to
summarize all the sentences that I have
seen I've heard up to this point and
this context is formal so for example I
may know that you are talking about a
restaurant and you've got information
already about location and so forth so
that's the input context so what we
asked what we add to it as input is the
next user sentence the next user
sentence comes in we go through this
neural network and at the end of that is
is a new context that summarized you
know the whole in the now the entire
conversation you know basically the old
context plus the new sentence and the
output is the new sentence
sorry the output is the new context as
you can see here is that our approach is
to make everything really formal this is
the only way we can really say that we
understand what the users are saying and
so that's the diagram of the neural
network and and you know more details in
an upcoming paper so the preliminary
results that we have seen is that by
using only synthetic data we have can
achieve a turn-by-turn accuracy of 60%
on the domain of restaurants emoji was
you're very excited about that result
and this is really early-stage result
and we have to do more work on more
domains and so forth but I think that
this concept of just getting a table and
automatically we generate you the
training data as well as the agent at
the end of that that can respond that
work that can converse with the user is
really exciting then there is another
experiment that we have done using this
kind of approach and that is it's a zero
shot learning result we mentioned multi
was a number of times it's a multi
domain dialogue benchmark and what we
try to do is to say suppose I have
training for training data for n domains
when I want to go to a new domain is it
possible for me to transfer the learning
for the N domain so I don't have to have
to do all the work all over again for
the new domain so this is the idea
behind transfer learning and in our
experiment it does zero shot learning
meaning that I
withhold all training data for the
domain of question okay so suppose I am
interested in domain X we really really
take all the original real training data
and we replace the real training data of
domain X was just synthetic data
it cost us basically nothing we just we
basically withhold all the real data put
in the Train synthetic data for X and
then we train with all the different
domains and then we test on the domain X
okay and we discovered that our
synthetic data takes you up to 73
percent of what you can achieve using
real data to Train so this is a this is
a good result because it saves people a
lot of effort in creating in group in in
gathering annotated data and this result
will be coming up in the ACL conference
this year and so those are the two
results is like we are able to answer
complex questions more accurately we now
have the first neural dialogue state
machine and the third topic is file
tease and privacy that was our original
motivation of this work so to start with
what we have done is that we separated
the AI from the execution all right
today the translation from natural
language to thing talk is done in the
cloud because we haven't finished we're
not done with training right but in the
future once it is trained it is passed
it is possible and it is probably kamal
cost-effective and definitely better for
privacy
if the inference is done locally okay
but nonetheless the translation from
natural language to the command in
formal language does not cause a huge
privacy issue in the following way
suppose i say what is my checking
account balance you know that in the
cloud it no it knows that i'm asking for
that all it does is to translate that
english
to the command of checking my checking
balance the code the past the code is
actually execute by the virtual
assistant our virtual system is called
almond and we have a version that runs
completely locally on your own devices
so the passwords execution there was
turn result it's only seen by almond on
your own device okay so this is the way
for us to give the user full privacy of
their data so so in our system you know
it's like I what I expect is that people
to have chocolate to have choice and the
second thing that we really need to make
sure of is that we can share our
information we know that by supply with
Facebook by providing sharing Facebook
was able to gather the data from
billions of people's from billions of
people so what we are saying here is the
sharing is very fundamental to what
people need so we break that into our
system from day one okay so that means
that I have my local system you may have
your local system and for us to share we
have a standard protocol for these
assistants to talk to each other that's
why it has to be it this is a fair way
to architecture the protocol is actually
very rich it is picking talk and it is
remote thing talk okay so anything that
I can do I can share with my friends I
will show you more details later alright
so one thing I want to mention is that
the almond has been integrated with home
assistance which is an open source
community of about a hundred thousand
people and what they have is an open
source gateway and it's already
connected to hundreds of different IO
T's and so and what almond is is a voice
interface to the local gateway
so now you can use all men to talk about
your thermostats or
security camera none of those
information from the IOT devices ever
need to leave your house you will just
be managed by the home assistant gateway
and then we provide you with the voice
interface to it so our our assistant now
IOT assistant is actually much more
powerful than the commercial ones we
don't just help you turn on the light
turn on the TV and so forth we actually
let you have these event-driven
operations so here I want to give you an
example to so that you can understand
they the you know you look at this
scenario to understand the power of this
technique so for example bob bob is a--
is unfortunately and asthma patient and
there are a lot of things a lot of IOT s
out there they can help them but having
all men which is a virtual assistant
next supports privacy is great because
he doesn't have to disclose his
condition to anybody you know to anybody
at all yes full privacy so with with
what we have done
bob can for example use almond to help
him manage his conditions he can say to
almond is like when i use my inhaler
record my GPS location in this lock file
on box ok because he might want to know
where he normally gets his asthma
attacks and it is not something that he
will care to do as soon as he is getting
his attack but every time he picks up
the inhaler the IOT inhaler it can
automatically trigger this kind of a
command that assists me the almond
assistant can do for you or Bob can say
you know I
I'm worried I may be taken to the
hospital and I want to you know it's
like almond let my dad know if I'm at
the hospital
so almond is the virtual assistant that
keeps track of where Bob is the whole
time ever you know but unless he gets
into trouble like being taken to the
hospital his father doesn't know where
he is
right so the assistant is providing the
communication of information when it is
needed
according to Bob's instruction in the
same way this information can be shared
with the doctor and the doctor for
example can monitor pops flow leader and
the doctor can also tell as assistant
tell the assistant that when if the like
when the air quality index is above some
level and you know Bob is running please
want him just tell him to stop okay
so now you can kind of have a
combination of information about Bob's
activities environment and so forth and
the virtual assistant being private is
has is you know is as you can see here
has information about Bob with and and
blog doesn't have to worry about having
any of this information leaking to a
third party but as you can see here
there is a whole lot of different
commands this is specific to Bob and
with the natural language programming he
is able to just say what he wants
instead of trying to ask somebody to
code all these little programs up for
him okay so that's the idea behind
behind our work so what I have shown you
was a thing tougher queries we have also
extended think talks they talk to let
you have event driven event triggered
commands okay so for example a command
like when I use my inhaler get my GPS
location if it is not home right it's a
lock well inbox is actually translated
into this thing TOC syntax
three lines on the natural language side
three lines on the code size
monitoring that your inhaler use getting
the GPS checking for the location and do
it ticking the results and writing into
the box file okay so this high-level
construct is I mean this has a very
simple grammar it is when something gets
something do something but the power
comes from the fact that this is hooking
up all the different thing pedia operate
up cooking up all the different
operations the inhaler the GPS the box
all these api's are stored in thing
pedia and thing talk is just a little
control construct that combines all
these things together and and you don't
have to remember how each each of these
api's are described in thing period
because the Louie net the neural network
will be able to handle natural language
versions of the left-hand side of the
sentences you know it just it makes it
you don't have to use the same words
with this neural network it will still
know what you were trying to say okay so
that's the high level idea so right now
we have besides the homeless systems
health of coyotes there are a whole
bunch of social social media and common
websites information API sand are
included in thing PDO today and so this
is not this is a little bit more
this is fancier than schema schemas as
always like you're doing joints
projections and feel lookup and stuff
like that but for IOT s there are a lot
of times it's one-of-a-kind
so if you look at Twitter so you can say
their API is from monitoring tweets and
then the user has to supply for example
how monitoring works so I can say when
at Stanford tweets it corresponds to
this code on the right so so what people
have to supply it's cut this is kind of
like the equivalent of the field
annotations here is API call here's a
snippet API
all sleep so that's what they think
pedia are they with the sick thing PDA
repository is about okay and then things
up hook them up together it allows the
information from all these different
devices to interoperate we have not seen
anything like this in the in commercial
assistance so things because a very
simple grammar when get and do but it
also has a lot of filters a lot of
predicates and with this simple
construct all the things that I were
talking about could be mapped into this
thing top grammar okay though the red is
the when get is the orange colored and
then the greens are the do's and then so
you can generate many many possible
sentence programs using natural language
so these are all the things that I can
get my assistants to do and the
interesting thing here is that we for we
can also turn it around for sharing okay
when we so whatever your assistant can
do the results can be shared with
anybody you care to share with all right
and all we have to do is to take the
sentences and add one more component to
it and that is that you can't you can
designate or specify who can execute
those commands so for example I can say
let dr. Smith monitor my peak flow meter
if it drops below that level or I can
say let my secretary whenever I'm out of
town read my email messages if the
subject is marked urgent okay so this is
a very detailed description of who when
how what the the person can see topic by
topic
alright what I do for a male's are very
different from my health records
another example here is that for example
with Coppa
websites need to know that you have a
user under 13 so I can say let websites
know I'm under 13 years old and so forth
okay so with natural language you can
really describe all all kinds of
different access controls in a very
natural way and I think this is
something that the world needs and so
far our access control for consumers are
in pretty bad shape you know you can
share with friends or friends or friends
but you really cannot put in on these
conditions as you can see here that is
meaningful to people all right so now I
want to show you how we can do sharing
so here is an example okay suppose the
dad says to his daughter is this well
you know you are always out of town and
you have the security camera if
something goes wrong I really should
help you manage the you know watch
what's going on in your apartment
so dad would say to his daughter Alice
is like I need to to help you so so in
our model dad will say to Alice's
assistant it says ask Alice to notify me
when her security camera detects motion
so he would say it in English the
request comes through Alice assistants
look at this request translates it into
code okay so that is the code that says
this is what you want me to do all right
so the next thing Alice's assistant does
is the checks against the access control
policy it was like has Alice given dad
the access control but you know Alice is
not an IT staff and she's not going to
write down all the things that anybody
can do for his for her on her digital
assets but it doesn't matter because
Alice can now you know if this can this
this this request is not already allowed
the AL Alice
Alyce's almond can go ask alice if
that's allowed so the whole idea here is
that the request is going to be executed
by Alice's assistant Alice is Alice's
assistant is the only one that actually
knows the passwords and it is supposed
to just show the results to death but
anytime that you are executing a remote
program it is very vulnerable to
security issues but in this case because
the language because the code is so high
level Alice can actually take the code
and translate it back into English fully
hundred-percent okay
and ask Alice if that is allowed so here
is an example of a sentence dad wants to
get notified when any event is detected
on your security camera and house motion
is equal to true okay it's a little
clunky but it is exactly what this
program says and now at this point Alice
can say yes can say no but typically
I'll let you know when you ask for
something like this if you think a
little bit harder you a real Alice will
realize it's like no I'm not going to
look like my dad look at my security and
camera anytime he wants but it is useful
if I am out of town okay
so Alice can say only if I am NOT at
home this clause of only if I'm not at
home can be combined with the request
and that is saved into the policy and
this program is executed and only if all
the conditions are true will the result
be sent to death okay so in other words
you no longer have to share your
passwords if you want to share
information with your friends your
secretary or dad and what not everything
is done by the assistant and only the
desired information or they the allowed
information is to it's shared with the
person who you are willing to share with
and so this is roughly how it works I
don't have the time to go into it
everything is very formal we are
actually using SMT satisfiability
modular theory in order to make sure
that the request is satisfied by the
policies that's the user sets up okay so
in summary here is that we now have a
privacy IOT privacy architecture the IOT
data never leave the house if you don't
want it to and in this mean time it
allows you to share anything that you
your virtual system can get access to
with fine grained access control all in
natural language okay so that's our
third result and well I want to
summarize here is that we are putting
out a new methodology and toolkit that
allows people to write their own natural
language interfaces and and the
developers they own it okay I don't own
it you take the tools that we have you
can build your interface and you can put
it on your own website your own app your
own phone and so forth and if you care
to if you want people to be able to
access it via virtual system we have a
privacy-preserving purchase in common
that will execute this code locally and
you don't have to worry about a a
proprietary platform that is
intercepting the communication and if
desired the same skills can execute on
everything that we like the the Amazon
Alexa and Google and so forth and as a
matter of fact we know how to take the
skill that you put into thing pedia and
have it automatically appear on amazon
and google because and using their third
party platform and hopefully many more
companies will have would like to tap
into these third party platforms and
besides the general purpose of Alexa
assistants like Alexa's and Google's and
and Syria and so forth we imagine that
the automobiles the hotels you know they
will also want to provide assistance by
voice and the same skill will also be
available on messengers and slack and so
forth so the whole concept here is to
try to recreate that idea that all the
skills are publicly available right and
and accessible to everybody okay so in
summary here is that we have laid out
this foundation for a lot of people to
put information up my voice and we
really need to to expand this effort and
for that we have this new lab the open
virtual assistant lab it's a new
affiliate program and we are looking
forward to working with out with
companies and getting sponsorships and
try to build out this open voice
internet with privacy protection thank
you